miles de toneladas de desechos en el
desierto de atacama uno de los más
bellos de América del Sur aquí hay
restos de carrocerías por miles y ropa
más allá de donde alcanza la vista
hecho Esta es una montaña de ropa
solamente que está tapada con tierra
una camisa de Cualquiera podría terminar
aquí porque estas toneladas de prendas
provienen del mundo entero
hay otras que están en perfecto estado
como este vestido fabricado en India
todo constituye una amenaza para el
medio ambiente según está activista
y no preguntarnos es que fue Juanito es
que son las Office sino que es decir
esto es tu terreno Y acá tienes metidas
muchas toneladas de ropa que son un
peligro son un riesgo ambiental son un
peligro para la salud de las personas ya
y no corresponde
estos últimos años el desierto de
atacamas se ha llenado de divertidos no
autorizados
chiles especializa en el comercio de
segunda mano
la mercancía llega hasta aquí a través
del puerto de iquique proveniente de
Europa de Asia o de Estados Unidos antes
de ser llevada al mercado chileno o
exportada a los países vecinos salvo una
parte de la mercancía que se queda en el
desierto de atacama abandonada por los
intermediarios el alcalde de una de las
comunas de la región denuncia la
pasividad del estado es como el patio
trasero ya ni siquiera somos el patio
trasero local sino que somos parte
trasero del mundo que es peor si no hay
conciencia todavía para poder resolver
este problema por el contrario no
chile recibe cada año unas 59 mil
toneladas de ropa y mucha termina
perjudicando el medio ambiente como en
este caso en el desierto de atacama